kaylynn is with us in Tulsa Oklahoma
hi Kailin how are you I am good
hi I'm 14 and I have my $500 emergency
fund already and my question was what
percent of my minimum-wage paycheck
should I invest in save and the kind of
investing can I use right now you're
pretty amazing you're on it kiddo I got
a feeling you're getting ready to be in
everyday millionaire before we know it
so who's paying for your car when you
turn 16 I'm going to pay for my car okay
and so the larger portion of your
paycheck you save the nicer car you're
going to get because that's your main
savings goal right now so there's three
things we do with four things we do with
money we work to create it you're doing
that way to go
high five way to go Rockstar number two
thing we're doing to create money or
once we create money by working we give
it save it and spend it and of course
the more we do of any one of those three
the less there is for the other two and
so it's that dance that we begin between
those three things that we will dance
with the rest of our lives
and it's a wonderful thing for you to
build all three muscles the spending
muscle wisely carefully not too much
the giving muscle liberally generously
the saving muscle called car and so I'll
tell you what happened to my kids when
they were your age once they started
breaking the money up into three
categories like that were Christians and
so they were tithing a tenth of their
income that was there giving portion and
so then past that they were saving for
their car and they were spending their
spending pretty much went down to very
little and the other thing that happened
was they started looking for ways to
make more money than minimum wage
because babysitting you can make twenty
bucks an hour dog sitting and walking
you can make 15 20 bucks an hour mowing
grass you can make more than that
so you know it's just whatever you want
to do but you can sure make more than
minimum wage even has a 14 year old
matter-of-fact both of my daughters went
and got the little YMCA certification
for babysitting they where they learn
CPR and they learn a few other things
and that kind of stuff so they were
certified babysitters that's a big deal
and anyway they used it I'll tell you
they they they worked their little tails
off and you know they worked the book
table at our live event selling books
off the back table and that kind of
stuff when we worked them my son painted
the stairwell here when he was fifteen
inside this building and it's a big old
building and a big old stairwell took
him a while they didn't do so good see
I'd do half of it over and so you know
that all comes into getting paid for the
car but it was a whole lot more than
minimum wage in every case and then
that's that's what I that's what
happened to them they cut their spending
down so that they could save more
because they start saying how I'm 14 I
got two years what kind of car my going
by $2,000 $1,000 a year that's 80 bucks
a month and you start doing some
goal-setting and dividing out how much
you need to be saving and you start
going I gotta get a better job
probably hey good call you're gonna be
alright
proud of you very well done